ん
[音楽]
えっえっ
b
[音楽]
言うじゃんはぁっ
普通
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
ん
うん
[音楽]
金さーん
ああいう社長です風さあはいというわけでものを飛ばずには絶好のたぜの強さ私
ダークネス井上という大きな名ぐるみのクマ思ってるんですけども
飛ばしたやつ飛ばしたいなと思いまして彼を何とか河川敷まで持ってきました
そしてすでに拝領の風船準備しました
ん
今回の実験は大きなクマのぬいぐるみ風船直子で飛ぶのか検証していきたいと思います
という夢じゃないですか兄弟なんでくると部の
結構やばい量の風船が必要だと思って事前たくさん風船準備したんでこれからたくさん
つけてってラークで誠意の秒
公共に返そうと思いますて早速も風船た気をつけていこうと思いますレッツゴーん
zard が続い言葉はまずダークネスの首にひも付けて風船つけやすいように紐付け
ていこうと思いますお願いしまーす
ん
ダークレス井上の首のここらへんに風生つければ規模の準備ができたんで
風体をつけていきます5100個ずつで準備するんで100個ずつくらいいます
[音楽]
まだ飛ばそう100個でも想像やばいんですけど坊勢つけてみようと思います
もうちょっとイケそうぞ棟あり給りらくつけまーす
[音楽]
やばいん
あるだけだグラフ200
[音楽]
ita で結構たくさんついたんですけど風船が多すぎてなんか外れそうなんで1回
ところ補強します
[音楽]
wh
着物補強して一番ほどしたって災害します
まだいいんだぞ
ああ
教えお腹もの頃にかけている状態ですこれからえぐれてますけどもうちょいつけたら
浮きそうな気がします頑張ります
あああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
もうちょいきそうなんでどんどんつけていきますねー
9分
[音楽]
てるザッっ
はい守ってもらってるんですけども事実できるぐらいには来ましたぜっ
感覚なってきましたただこの風船の量でもまだ浮かないんでもう2必要っぽいねつけて
います
百姓かねぇ
[音楽]
もうちょいれ富山はいもう一息ですもうここまで来ると中川伏せの数とかじゃなく
ちょいず飛ばせくなってきましたということでここからはさらに巨大な風船を使って
いきたいとおもいます
ザーって狩りがつけばいい
歩兵
結構えぐいことになってきたんもうちょい池ソースるってこと文化
不安のやってよってねー
しまって
もう沿いん
は頑張りゃ初音もう少しで頑張りますああ
[音楽]
ええええええ
をしないわーああああああこれ
坊主やばいいきます
me
入っちゃった
花しまーす
いたが違ったからもう一いっぽいです
ん
ああああああ
おおーー
欧州準備した約86万円の資産をすべて使って
ガスが切れてヘリウムガスが切れてこれが今済みている災害の風船量ですご覧ください
若干浮いてます
ほぼ浮いていると言っても過言じゃないんですけども今日風が強いんで凧揚げみたいに
走ったら多分
浮くんじゃないかということで
走ってみますおっを拭いたら
わー
[拍手]
el
[音楽]
うぇっは
ん
uh